[Applause]
that was one of the greatest AAU teams
of all time Ronnie and Open brand you
know that was a hell of a front line
alone
Lamar Odom you know you're not gonna
beat that team I think that for those
kids they formed a kind of aristocracy
of talent with that team symbolizes was
that there was no going back the ship
was now final that the path of the game
was inexorable the real team the money
team was going to be the AAU squads not
your high school team
Lamar Odom had a six-inch growth spurt
now he went from 61 to 67 from like 9th
to 10th grade silky-smooth point guard
it was almost not fair because I'm like
a 6 for Center and they're telling me I
got talented I'm watching him and just
move and pass the ball unselfish just
amazing player and brought our test was
the enforcer you know that's that's who
he is that's what we was defensive
stopper that's where we learned how to
play unselfishly we always knew the mall
was his most skills Elton was the best I
was pretty damn good Ron always made the
right basketball player it's like he
learned the game to Jewish some icky all
that being said there was something
scary about it it was a look in his eyes
you didn't want to mess with him
because he could go off on
[Applause]
we're playing a tournament in st. Louis
and this is their home tournament and
the guy was scoring a little too much
four rounds like it and he ended up you
know punching him in the face coming off
the pick it was a jaw that was a
displaced but that's the round was he's
he had pride in his defense I remember
he was watching a high school game and
it was game before us and this guy guy
all minors and I throw him down like 20
sets of bleachers from really high up it
was pretty bad brawl just picked him up
over his head like just do enough this
actually I was crazy wrong when he goes
there ain't no stopping him
I didn't really care you know what I was
doing I didn't really care about anybody
what they thought you know all I know is
I'm here to play basketball if the hell
out of cleaners for a little bit
[Applause]